ce que je peux vous dire maintenant que
le centre ville de beyrouth
le centre il est quasiment pas de vitre
mais le sou qui a tout détruit je vois
pas ça moi ce qu'on appelle le centre de
leconte le complexe de ce biais long il
ya les conneries tout ça il est
complètement détruit le bord des routes
à mon avis le fort est complètement est
complètement détruit le entendu jusqu'à
qaïda qui a 40 km de beyrouth même je te
témoigner ma manière qui habite à chypre
je répète à chypre ils ont entendu
l'explosion
ça je viens juste de parler avec
magnette et à chitral maty sarr tout le
liban a quasiment entendu l'explosion
c'est un souffle énorme quelqu'un
lalalalala plus bardés d infoman on
parle de l'explosion dont un dans un
container ou dans un bandeau il ya le
stockage de feu d'artifice on n'a pas
d'idées mais la couleur à l'été rouge là
jusqu'à maintenant je peux je peux
témoigner que je vois encore la fumée
mais les dégâts sont partout même au
monde y vont donc on parle avec un vol
d'oiseau d'une trentaine de kilomètres
et les vitres ont été complètement
cassés sont la situation allait aller
jusqu où il vient d'arriver ne facilite
pas la tâche au liban avec le problème
de corona on a commenté la manon est la
deuxième phase du confinement
on n'arrive pas à contrôler le problème
avec la situation économique et
financière pouvait entendre maintenant
la sirène à côté de moi de s'être donc
le liban n'avait sûrement ne pouvait pas
encore en corse de cauchemar au concours
de cordes des routes pas être en arrêt
pendant des semaines voire des mois
c'est un témoignage personnel je peux
voir maintenant le port quasiment
quasiment détruit même il y a des
bateaux qui sont qui sont quasiment
tombé dans l'eau quelque chose comme ça
j'ai le dollar il était autour de 8000
dans ce sens-là manon la monnaie
libanaise va encore aller dans vaches
chute libre face au dollar qui vient
d'arriver
on n'est pas encore là le jure de 2,2
d'analyser les conséquences qui peuvent
tomber mais ça va être encore une
catastrophe
le liban vit des moments rééditer
rappeler la déflagration était
extrêmement puissante ressentir à
plusieurs kilomètres au delà de la de la
zone du port où les explosions ont eu
lieu
on évoquait il ya un instant des
dizaines de blessés est-ce que vous avez
davantage d'informations sur ce point qu
est il dit en ce moment sur les
télévisions libanaises qui on l'imaginé
suivent en direct la situation sur place
malheureusement moi j'ai pris la
diffusion personnellement d'aller vers
la barre et la vente de lait cru aux
gens dont je suis patrie par la télé
mais vu une explosion hic il y a à côté
de ceux du port disons qu'on appelle la
quarantaine karatina les anciens à côté
du port et avec l'explosion et avec le
souffle de l'explosion
je vois mal comment on peut pas avoir un
bilan très lourd
malheureusement par des membres mais
aussi des blessés le souffle est énorme
donc les gens qui sont au port et les
gens qui sont bonnes mais dans les
habitations qui sont les les ondes
pauvre voire les lez lille et on peut
dire à l'extérieur de la ville vont des
plus démunis qui habite à côté du port
sont touchées en armement et je pense
qu'on a besoin peut-être depuis hier
jour pour pouvoir savoir le nombre
exactement j'espère que mon analyse je
ne sois pas exact mais du les bulles du
8 qui se passe quand on va avoir un
bilan très très élevé et il faut aussi
noter qu'à côté du port il ya pas mal de
deux ouvriers et des entrées est rangé
des immigrés qui travaillent au liban
donc il y a on va avoir un très grand
nombre de personnes qui habitent dans le
secteur dans le 1 km carrés qui
entourent l'explosion danse le bilan
humain s'élève que nous
vous qui êtes sur place actuellement
dans cette zone du port touché les
dégâts matériels on le rappelle sont
extrêmement lourd quelles forces de
sécurité sont déployés sur place c'est
ce que vous avez sentiment que les
victimes sont prises en charge comme il
le faut comment réagit aussi comment
réagissent les autorités quel message
est envoyé à la population en ce moment
même n'a jusqu'à maintenant tout ce
qu'ils fassent cesser le travail sur les
questions de pouvoir sortir les blessés
de l'intérieur et autrui des saignées de
table le jeu car pour l'apprendre la
lymphe antilles il contenu et je vois
pas moi maintenant les fumées qui
changent de couleur alpha sa maman de du
noir jusqu'aux un peu le gris donc ça
veut dire qu'ils rencontrent lui un aléa
brûlé le nôtre l'autre problème est que
les hôpitaux au liban son don déjà sont
déjà on va dire surchargé par le coran
avery aujourd'hui à l'hôpital public
central de beyrouth pour photographier
kabyle est annoncé et sa durée car les
par les personnes atteintes de la grippe
a là je pense que les hôpitaux à
beyrouth sont surchargés il ya des
appels la maman aurait tourné pour les
bons de son conte comment ça les gens
tendent à beyrouth
mais la zone est bouclée par les forces
par les forces militaires mais si je
peux vous expliquer là on parle sur les
chutes sur la méditerranée le corps et
les quasiment au centre ils engendrent
des centre-ville de beyrouth
donc la grande mer contre 8 après la
guerre il y à une aronde bien qu'aucun
vitre qui a qui avait sauvé il ya des
fata mois l'immeuble historique de
journal du quotidien al ahram le plus
ancien du liban il est quasiment détruit
et on a vu des blessés qui viennent de
sortir de l'immeuble dans ce que la
situation allait gr b on a besoin de
fonds
de plusieurs heures voire plusieurs
jours pour pouvoir comprendre ce qui est
arrivé et pouvoir un peu estimé la lala
l'étendue de la gravité de la situation
et non depuis paris on évoque aussi de
nombreux habitants blessés qui marchent
dans les rues en direction des hôpitaux
ce sont des scènes auxquelles vous
insistez vous aussi là maintenant je
suis moi je vois à mais on a vu que ça
n'allait pas je pense que le fait que
c'est normal car les gens qui habituent
à côté les vitres ne sont pas juste
exclu et c'est un souffle donc
pratiquement le vert transforme en arme
de guerre dans ce sens là donc les
personnes qui sort déjà et sont sous le
choc je peux témoigner qu'il y a eu des
immeubles et ne noie un moment donné on
a senti que c'était un très bon
tremblement de terre à beyrouth donc
quand l'actuel le souple festivement
qu'au départ on a cru que c'était un
tremblement de terre donc juste imaginer
à quel point cet effort donc les gens
qui vont courir ce sont des gens qui
sont sous le choc ils comprennent pas ce
qui arrive
ils sont sous le choc total le
traumatisme est total et donc ils n'ont
aucun et je le vois ne censure donc la
seule solution c'est de courir pour
demander de hleb et sam
on évoque aussi des contenaires qui se
trouvaient sur cette zone du port quels
sont les analyses à ce sujet que vous
entendez vous qui êtes à beyrouth
on en entend on a entendu beaucoup
d'histoires mais moi j'ai pu voir
quelques vidéos là là là je peux
témoigner que je vois le décor terre de
l'armée libanaise qui veulent juste un
chiffre de soude au dessus de moi je
pense qu'il veut a chargé de l'eau pour
essayer de participer à la hâte et de
tendre un fonds dit qu'apparemment il
n'arrive pas
ils ne peuvent pas contenir le feu mais
ce que je peux dire que pratiquement il
ya un vidéo où on commence à entendre
déclare véritablement comme des feux
d'artifice donc ce qu'on peut voir il ya
eu un premier incendie et après 7
minutes
il y a
l'énorme explosion donc il ya eu un
incendie peut-être dans un container au
dans un stock apporte raison qu il ya
les feux d'artifice et un moment donné
il ya eu une énorme explosion
est ce que le feu d'artifice en grande
quantité qui peut exploser en parle de
temps et de temps tu peux faire ceci je
suis pas un expert mais ça c'est le
scénario privilégié ce cas là où votre
intime et là je te vois là je peux voir
l'armée l'hélicoptère et commenta a
participé à la hâte un dollar
merci annie mourad je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur de droit activistes
politiques avaient route